[Music]
okay one of the big cultural
norms
uh cultural myths is that a college
degree is the best way to success
now that may have been true
based on where culture was 30 years ago
40 years ago it's not true anymore as
education continues to evolve as
technology
evolves
and one of the things i wanted to point
out
george is a recent yahoo news story
that talks about a new report that shows
which colleges offer the best roi so we
got a lot of money uh questions and
calls obviously people are gonna win
with their money on the show and so roi
standing for return on investment so if
you think about how much money you spend
over four years and and here's the deal
the data shows us that a lot of kids are
taking five to six years so this is a
let's call it a four to six year spend
on college all right and so just
touching on a few things from the
article um
the report uh has a calculator uh where
you can go in and you can search 3 300
colleges in the united states
and from this report you see a lot of
technical institutions
uh science and engineering
type institutions tend to have a greater
roi right because of the explosive
growth in those areas and you know the
the the even the entry level in those
areas is is quite nice
um and here's how they came up with it
how they come up with
because i think this is important for
consumers is they're thinking what's the
right school for my kid what's the right
school for me more on that in a second
but this report basically took
the college earnings premium which is
the pay bump that students would get
after graduation or as a result of
graduation
and they divide that number by the cost
of tuition
and then it's going to take into account
a range of other factors like student
debt
to how long it takes to complete it so
what are you racking up in debt how long
is it taking to get to the degree as
well as
uh what are the labor market challenges
that graduates will face to give you an
example of what i'm talking about here
we know
that over 50 percent i think it was
about 52
of college graduates in 2021 took six
months
to find a job in the field they went to
be trained for so this takes into
account that as well yeah uh and so
we're not going to dive into this very
deeply but public institutions via this
report this roi calculator george tended
to do much better the private non-profit
institute institutions were next and in
the private for-profit institutions not
so good uh-oh so now let me just call
this out because this is a trap
the private for-profit institutions that
did not have a good roi in fact
according to this report just 69 percent
offered a pri a positive return is and i
don't want to name names and hack
anybody off sure but you know they're
out there they're they're for-profit and
they're big box it's like hey come here
we'll get you trained for continuing
education blah blah blah so be careful
i'm looking at some interesting numbers
here on the calculator
i typed some schools in just to see just
to see my alma mater has a two hundred
thousand dollar positive roi oh very
nice texas tech
dr john dolone's alma mater has a
million dollar roi
typed in harvard university just to see
three million dollar roi and so that's
what they're saying uh it's very
interesting but to look at different
schools and this varies person to person
you know if you get a full ride well
that changes the game versus going
300 000 and let's also understand we are
not endorsing this calculator i want to
be very clear i'm saying it's a very
interesting interesting tool it's an
interesting tool but i think you've got
to take into effect the student loan
nonsense yes and what you're going to
saddle yourself with and i'm just going
to say this to everybody listening and
watching when was the last time you went
to the doctor's office or the dentist
office or
sitting down with your cpa and before
you
decided to pay them for their services
did you ask them to show you their
diploma
nobody cares i scan the wall looking at
the frames i know you do george but
you're neurotic nobody else does that uh
and no he's we're kidding he doesn't do
that so this is the point
let me just also give you a two-part
question that i'm trying to help parents
grasp
is college
the only way
for your kid to get where they want to
go
secondary question is it the best way if
the answer is no to either one of those
please be okay going to the block party
or the golf course or the soccer game
and going hey my kid's going into trade
school
stop being ashamed of it for crying out
loud i'm it it wears me out the shame
that we've put on community colleges on
trade schools on state schools even and
it's got to stop because it's putting
our kids in chains for 20 years so that
the parents can feel good so they can
brag to their friends about where their
kid went to school yeah it's become
about status folks
don't go for the football team don't go
for the landscaping don't go for the
water slide if you've got to get the
degree
get it
if it's the best way to get where you
want to go do it if it's not get over
yourself and this is a great pitch for
everyone to go watch borrowed future
it's 88 minutes long you've got to see
this sit down with your kids parents if
you don't know how to have this
conversation this documentary can be a
great place to start this is a
world-class documentary we put out late
last year uh it's like five bucks to go
watch this thing you can get on amazon
prime on apple tv at our website
barfuture.com and listen to the podcast
that's a free resource borrowed future
we did eight episodes on that on the
student loan crisis and it was
eye-opening but it just made me go i
want to shake every student go there's
another way well you realize fall for
the training you realize that higher
education has become about their
fortunes not your futures amen so there
you go you should tweet that
yeah i'm working on that one you need to
spread that one